and just like that the Fox x-men movies
come to a close Dark Phoenix which is an
x-men movie you couldn't tell by the
title which is some odd reason you can't
because it doesn't say x-men dark fairy
so Dark Phoenix is the newest x-men
movie of the Fox x-men movies probably
the last two because now Disney owns Fox
20s as we saw from the trailer will do
in a space mission Jean Grey absorbs
basically the purple version of parallax
from the Green Lantern movie and now
Jean Grey has the Phoenix force
something I guess she didn't have before
when she absolutely positively had it an
x-men apocalypse and whatever now she is
the Dark Phoenix and since this is the
final send-off for the Fox x-men movies
in x-men 3 The Last Stand which had Dark
Phoenix in it kind of wasn't really the
Dark Phoenix people wanted people want
to see some good Dark Phoenix x-men [ __ ]
and this movie actually does have some
garbage it's not good it's it's all over
the place Jean Grey gets the Phoenix
force some people are going after her to
take her down some people are going
after her to help her and there's this
other faction basically Jessica Chastain
and friends can't really go into it
because the trailer didn't really go
into it but they're also going after her
and I get why they're in here because
you know from the comic book you don't
know much about Jessica Chastain and
Friends cuz the movie doesn't really
inform you too much about them so you
don't really care much about them so
they just feel like they're in the way I
know how important they were supposed to
be but they're not in this movie I'm
just saying Jessica Chastain and Friends
didn't offer anything other than there's
an action scene in the climax and even
then it takes place in a train so how
interesting is it really takes place in
a series of boxcars it's about as wide
as well a series of boxcars this is one
of those times at this comic book movie
like every comic book movie that's ever
happened they had to have that moment
where they're like all right what are we
cut out because the movie time we have
to make we have to make those calls
those tough calls and they probably
should have just cut them out or keep
Jessica Chastain and friends and split
this into two movies which maybe they
were wanting to do that but the fact
that Disney bought Fox they wouldn't be
able to finish it so this is what we
have this movie that just feels like
it's crushed together that really comes
back to a time in comic book movie
history where studios were like we have
comic book characters we'll just have
them do stuff they don't have to do
anything interesting there doesn't even
have to be a story we can just have them
do [ __ ] that's what this movie feels
like it's just x-men characters doing
[ __ ] and that's
I will say man I'm about to say this
x-men The Last Stand at least had a plot
driving the whole thing forward there
was a kid they were harvesting a cure
and oh yeah by the way we have Dark
Phoenix also I'll sing that's great now
saying this how it should have been not
saying it works I'm just saying it works
more than this movie works doc man I
just said that and if you just look at
the motivations like Magneto we've seen
him we've seen his arc before in the
other x-men movies Magneto's laying low
trying to live the peaceful life series
of events have brought him out of hiding
and now he's going to join the action to
do a couple thing that's magneto in this
movie some of the characters choices
with a couple of the characters they
just they conflict with the characters I
personally now enter Jake Xavier and
Jake McCoy this was shown in the trailer
so I'll talk about it here Xavier in
this movie did the same thing he did and
x-men the last tank grindin x-men the
last and when Jean Grey was a little
girl I guess she had another personality
and Xavier repressed it that's actually
less of a dick move than what he does in
here and here Jean Grey just has a
traumatizing experience and Charles
Xavier is like I'll just block that out
of your mind and suppress that you can't
help her overcome her trauma
you have to repress that [ __ ] how
qualified are you exactly what is it you
do here we're gonna pass our kids off to
someone who can't really help kids
instead he just takes the easy route
like I'll just I'll just repress that
there so I don't actually have to work
cuz I'm actually really unqualified I
thought it was a dick call it made
Charles Xavier kind of a day also Jake
crawler there's two sea breezes
massacring people with his evil look in
his eyes was like oh nightcrawler
or as asel if you wanted to zeizel in
the movie could have just had him in the
movie but like oh he didn't die off
screen and there were bad guys but still
Nightcrawler is just straight-up
killing them like tail the neck
transports one in front of a vehicle
just smashes into him it either feels
like Azazel or Nightcrawler from the
beginning of x-men to when he was like
being controlled the [ __ ] on his neck a
pacing sucks too after Jean gets her
Phoenix powers and she flies away and
there's just like all the x-men are
mopey jeans most of the times like oh
it's good didn't they like alright we'll
just start throwing characters at her
and then she'll have to deal with that
and she'll run off and be like oh god do
I really want this and then she flies
away again and they're all mopey again
I'm like something needs to happen how
interesting can that be yeah that could
have just had
be this big evil if they now have to
take out but that would have been x-men
apocalypse would have been a little
redundant so you have the possibility of
redundancy or boredom what to do here's
what the studio should have done they
should have realized well it's above the
writers we have let's pay for better
writers that's it that's how you do it
you accept the fact that you don't know
what to do and you hire the people who
do know what to do or you realize
Disney's gonna buy her ass and who
really gives a [ __ ] will just throw
garbage out there maybe that was smarter
they dude they're like why would we pay
for better writers and was gonna watch
this also the special effects were ass
you can't even imagine what it would
have looked like if this movie had come
out when it was going to come out in
2018 all that time to refine it didn't
you just tell everyone just kind of they
were all over it
the actors were over it the studio was
over it everyone wanted to be like all
right you know what x-men is done we're
hanging it up we're over it felt like no
one gave a [ __ ] anymore
I feel like this movie was just a big
waste of time and if they're wasting my
time I'm not going to let them waste
your time just stay away from it let's
go through it this movie's not as good
as the first x-men movie not as good as
x-two x-men United not as good as x-men
3 The Last Stand not as good as x-men
origins Wolverine it's not as good as
x-men first class it's not as good as
x-men Days of Future past it's not as
good as x-men apocalypse certainly not
as good as Logan it's the worst x-men
movie I would watch any one of those
before I watch this again because at
least those ones look like they were
trying to tell a story this looks like
it was written and/or directed by that
guy and then Dark Phoenix the movie ends
and like the sound of a toilet flushing
you know well now that's over it's the
end of an event in summing up this movie
as a great philosopher once eloquently
and famously said and it is this movie
is truly a mess guys this is dark but
Dark Phoenix is [ __ ] oh my god I
didn't even stay for the post-credit
scene like there might have been a
post-credits scene in here but I didn't
care alright so dark Phoenix have you
seen it what did you think about it or
list your x-men movies best to worst
worst to best however you want to list
them and is this one on the bottom or am
I just a dick
whatever you think comment below let me
know and like I've said before when you
guys hit that like button it really
helps the video out helps the channel
out so if you liked this video or you
have a level of disdain for the
the x-men movies or shitty comic-book
movies in general or shitty movies in
general you hit that like button that
would really help me out and I would
appreciate it and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]